what female has been the most forward
with you oh man yeah our fans get a
little you know they're great they're
they're you know like he said his was
pretty that was pretty aggressive mine
are more like slick and you know they
come right in on you and like we'll be
we go see fans all the time to be like
can you sign this can you sign that yeah
yeah yeah and this one girl was just
like right away she's like can you sign
my vagina what you penis yes it can't
get done what what color ink it depends
on what you ate I think we've gone too
far I think we've gone GFR medical Tommy
how about you most forward female fan I
mean if I'd I've had the law I don't
mean
[Applause]
not quite the ways I manage to say but
they can I sneak up on you with these
pretty little boxes like this now that's
a cute little box wonder what's in here
knowing you that my vibrator they want
you to sign their vibrators yeah oh
thank you very much
no so that would be a no okay new yes
but you're coming out with your own line
of priests I know you're talking [ __ ]
things up with Walmart
you